હ
[Musique]
he
autour du monde des amoureux de la mer
se réapproprient le savoir-faire des
marins
d'autrefois en Polynésie française des
passionnés font voguer la pirogue de
leurs ancêtres sans aucun
instrument en Bretagne des apprentis
marins découvrent les flots et leurs
secrets sur un vieux gréement du siècle
dernier tous vont passer quelques jours
sur un bateau à l'école de la
[Musique]
mer
à 18000 km de la métropole au cœur de
l'océan Pacifique apparaît la Polynésie
française un chapelet de 118 disséminé
sur une surface grande comme
l'Europe
parmi elle Tahiti l'île
capitale dans le port de papette la
ville principale on aperçoit parfois une
curieuse
embarcation une réplique moderne des
grandes pirogues
traditionnelles celle qu'utilisaient les
navigateurs polynésiens il y a 3000 ans
pour voyager dans l'immensité
[Musique]
océanique aujourd'hui l'association
fafit fait revivre cette navigation
ancestraleiv comme
ça on va les Gour la limite ce matin ils
sont 12 à se préparer pour une prochaine
navigation dans les îles de
l'archipel TR contente de vous avoir
chaque navigation est différente
et chaque navigation a son lot de
challenge et là euh ça va je trouve que
ça va être chouette parce que ça va être
beaucoup de découvertes pour nous
tous étant donné qu'il y a beaucoup de
personnes qui n'ont pas beaucoup navigué
il y en a qui n'ont jamais
navigué comment ça marche la pirogue
derrière ici côté tribor on lave la
vaisselle uniquement côté Babor on se
douche uniquement ok on fait pas le
l'inverse ça c'est pour raison
d'hygiène la pirogue avance
principalement à la voile l'équipage
doit s'adapter à la météo on va vous
montrer comment on compte la vitesse
comment onévalue ce qui est amusant
aussi quelque part comme ça ça nous
permet aussi de de de se laisser guider
de se dire bon le vent est dans telle
direction on va on cible t oui au moins
si on
vain
ici et ben on aura le vent de travers on
a beaucoup de nouveaux donc ça peut du
coup être beaucoup plus facile ça nous
permet d'utiliser nos voiles
traditionnelles ça va être un bon
exercice on est issu d'une culture qui a
changé tellement rapidement il y a eu
plusieurs choses qui ont fait qu'elle a
été arrêtée notamment la venue dé
missionnaires notamment le changement de
vie rapide il faut savoir que nous nous
sommes quand même assez pratique le jour
où Ben il y a un moteur ben voilà on va
utiliser le moteur pourquo on va
utiliser des voles si si on m on va plus
vite et cetera et cetera donc ce qui
fait qu'on a perdu beaucoup de de
pratique et donc et ben on s'est éloigné
de de l'identité de nos ancêtres de la
façon d'être de la façon de penser de la
façon de
[Musique]
faire être marin polynésien un ntaille
comme on les appelle ici c'est aussi se
ré
une histoire
millénaire sur les hauteurs de papette
au fond de la vallée de Hamuta les
itille se retrouve sur un Mara un ancien
lieu de culte sacré pour un rituel qui
précède chaque grande
navigation est le maître de
[Musique]
cérémonie
it d'aller faire une ça symbolise la
cohésion encourager la cohésion entre
entre reocé tout ça c'est une cohésion
très générale mais symbolique
[Musique]
ai t les membres de la prochaine
expédition sont là don en tête la
capitaine c'est elle qui sera garante du
lien entre les marins sur la
pirogue
[Musique]
im
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Maine
Faé c'est pas une école de voile c'est
pas je veux naviguer je saute suré je
navigue non c'est c'est vraiment une
association culturelle c'est ser
réapproprié l'art de la navigation
ancestrale parce qu'on l'a perdu mais
c'est aussi surtout ser réapproprié ce
qu'on appelle les valeurs du va
c'està-dire les valeurs de la Py
demain les 12 marins vont entamer leur
voyage dans le
[Musique]
temps de l'autre côté du globe la
Bretagne est elle aussi une terre de
navigateur voici la rate de Brest cette
immense baie de 180 km² située à
l'extrême ouest du
Finistère c'est la deuxème base navale
française dans la rade les bâtiments
militaires les plus sophistiqués
croissent au large de
[Musique]
l'Arsenal ici depuis plusieurs siècles
on forme des
marins l'école de mestrance est l'une
des plus é de la Marine nationale
800 élèves il deviennent chaque année
sousofficiers de
marine pourtant même à l'air de la
technologie on apprend encore au jeunes
marins la navigation
traditionnelle demain 10 d'entre eux
embarqueront sur un voilier emblématique
de la Marine
nationale
bien un petit briefing avant votre
embarquement donc vous avez déjà
embarqué sur les bâtiments de la Marine
nationale notamment les les bâtiments
école là vous allez mettre le pied sur
une autre plateforme sur d'autres
bâtiments les voiliers de la Marine
nationale vous allez plonger dans
l'univers de la navigation
traditionnelle vous allez voir l'action
du vent dans les voiles vous allez voir
comment les voiliers prennent les vagues
de la mer du vent ou de la houle donc
vous allez tenir la barre vous allez
tirer sur les Boutes euh vous allez
avoir acquérir un vrai sens marin donc
je compte sur vous et bonne
mè alors pour partir il me faut la
salopette de car Louis a 18 ans la mère
pour lui est une passion
d'enfance j'ai beaucoup navigué avec des
scouts marins et en fait c'est eux qui
m'ont fait aimer la la la navigation
tracer des routes sur des cartes tirer
des Boutes et cetera connaître les
allures bah les bases en fait de la
navigation et euh j'ai direct été happé
par cet univers là c'est toujours une
grande découverte de naviguer sur des
vieux
bâtiments même si partir en navigation
sur des voiliers c'est intéressant mais
partir encore sur des viux grments c'est
un peu retrouver les
anciennes les anciens moyens de Na de
naviguer et
cetera chaque navigation est différente
du coup vraiment hâte d'être à demain
réellement
à 21 ans Eva n'a qu'un seul rêve en tête
j'ai décidé de faire marin pompier parce
que j'avais énormément envie de
voyager de naviguer d'être embarqué sur
bateau aussi et ça a été
vraiment une décision
réfléchie j'ai enfin j'ai envie d'être
sur les mers de voir du pays tout ça je
pense qu'on a une chance extraordinaire
de pouvoir partir sur sur un voilier
c'est vraiment l'occasion de voir un peu
la tradition de de la Marine nationale
ça je pense que ça va être un peu
rustique mais c'est ce que c'est ce que
j'attends aussi quoi vraiment j'ai super
hâte d'y
aller bon M comprimés pour pas être
malade et le
bonnet aès qui est accroché là-bas
derrière des T-shirts de rechange Romain
lui veut travailler à bord d'un
sous-marin t-shirt dans une journée en
trans pourtant lorsqu'on lui a proposé
de jours d'embarquement sur un voilier
traditionnel il n'a pas hésité oui ça ça
revient au à l'air même du marin c'est
il y a pas les moteurs pour aider la
propulsion c'est on y va à la voile on
fait tout aux étoiles il y a pas
d'instrument automatique de bord il y a
pas d'ordinateur il y a pas de radar
c'est vraiment la la mar la la
navigation à l'Étap en
fait c'est bon je crois que j'ai tout
pris c'est
[Musique]
fini dans la matinée Eva romain Louis et
se autres élèves embarquent sur la Belle
Poule une goelllette construite en
1932 réplique des voiliers mythiques qui
allaient pêcher la morue dans les mers
lointaines d'Islande la Belle Poule est
un naireécole de la Marine
[Musique]
nationale on va faire un petit tour du
bateau il y en a qui ont déjà fait de la
voile personne c'est vous êtes la petite
la voile plaisance quoi d'accord vous
allez voir ici on va vous parler chinois
au début quand on vous dira on vaer les
voiles d'avant faudra venir sur la plage
avant parce que c'est ici que ça va se
passer d'accord donc en partant du début
on a grand foc petit foc et la
trinquette ici là d'accord grand foc
petit foc trinquette donc ça fait GPT
d'accord c'est un moyen mémoechnique pas
très haut comme ça mais quand vous êtes
les élèves sontueill par Olivier le
bosco le maître des
manvres c'est lui qui va leur enseigner
les rudiments de la navigation
traditionnelle si vous comprenez pas
quelque chose vous nous faites répéter
on est là pour vous nous nous on connaît
le fonctionnement de la Golette on sait
comment ça marche maintenant on est là
pour vous donc hésitez pas à nous faire
répéter quand on vous dit tiens tu te
mets sur Dris tu fais ça si vous
comprenez pas vous nous dites moi tout
seul je fais rien ici d'accord j'ai
besoin de nous quand on navigue entre
nous j'ai besoin de tout le monde
d'accord avec les élèves j'auris vous et
là il vair travailler en équipe c'est
aussi ça le but de vous faire passer sur
ces bateau là d'accord c'est pouvoir
comprendre que ici on est obligé de
travailler en
équipe attention la
manvre l tout sa la
garde pendant de jours ces 10 jeunes
marins en devenir vont expérimenter la
mer et ses secrets sur ce splendide
vieux grément l'un des plus beau de la
Marine
nationale
ok retour en Polynésie dans le port de
papette
sur la pirogue de fa c'est l'heure des
derniers
préparatif l'autre responsable de cette
expéditioni quiîtrise la navigation
polynésienne une navigation gu par les
élés
[Musique]
naturelant
c'est
[Musique]
bon
on regarde noscêes et le
de naiger avec beaucoup d'admiration et
beaucoup de respect en fait c'est un
tout tout ceux qui souhaitent naviguer
ou ou se réapproprier cette
c'est aussi Ben se dire ok je suis
d'accord pour me réapproprier aussi
cette ma
culture mes valeurs enfin les valeurs
ancestrales la culture ancestrale voilà
ça fait ça fait partie d'un
[Musique]
tout
B avant le départ de la pirogue les
familles souhaitent bon vent au
passagers merci merci merci de
nous étudiants professeurs ou mare de
famille tous sont des
amateurs ils ont en commun l'amour de la
voile et de leur
traditionz
ciao bientôt il va venir ça va
aller
Ciao
vec aussi voil on un
pe permission de s de la
[Musique]
de
là on est ça y est là on est heureux on
va sortir bientôt on va sentir le vend
l la sortie du port se fait au
moteur à partir de maintenant la pirogue
sera guidé par le vent qui fait gonfler
les voiles en forme de pince de
[Musique]
crabe ces 12 marins vont apprendre à
naviguer comme leurs ancêtres à la
découverte des îles du
Pacifique
[Musique]
partout dans la rate de Brest sur la
Belle Poule les 10 jeunes élèves sont
déjà à la
manœuvre
première étape is les voiles de la
goéette plus de 450 m car de toile a
monté à la force des
[Musique]
bras c'est très
physique c'est c'est vraiment rustique
c'est pas comme un moteur qui nous qui
nous propulse avec une hélice là c'est
vraiment à la force des bras et de
l'homme je suis complètement novice tout
ce qui est voile le foc le petit foc le
grand foc le flèche enfin tout ça je n'y
connais absolument rien comment on
navigue à la voile en fait c'est une
grosse
[Musique]
initiation après une heure d'effort
intense le bateau file en voile
dehors la Belle Poule est une goélette à
hier du nom de sa petite voile carrée
dressé au sommet de son premier
m dans le monde elles ne sont plus que c
comme la Belle Poule en état de
[Musique]
naviguer naviguer sur ce bateau sur les
goilettes pour moi c'est c'est voil
c'est é flottant c'est chargé en
histoire c'est pour moi c'est les plus
c'est les plus beau voilier au monde
pratiquement quoi donc j'en ai vu
quelquesuns je suis amoureux de ces
bateaux là quo
vraiment naviguer à la voile à
l'ancienne c'est ça qui me plaît quoi
c'est l'esprit d'équipe ce qu'on
retrouve pas forcément sur d'autres
bateaux vraiment l'équipage un équipage
soudé et c'est ça que j'aime
à lâchez
tout
ces marins débutants sont habitués aux
appareils modernes de
navigation la voile traditionnelle est
pour eu une
découverte rochez-vous mettez-vous
autour du de la barre ici là mettez-vous
tous autour voici le cours de timonerie
pour apprendre à diriger un voilier avec
gouvernail et
boussol donc pour la barre donc il y a
deux choses qu'il faut comprendre sur un
bâtiment donc que ce soit un bateau à
voile ou un bateau
à moteur donc il y a la il y a le cap
donc le cap du Nord en passant par l'est
le sud l'Ouest donc ça fait une couronne
à
360°r donc là je vais vous faire
gouverner au 250 donc il y a le 250 vous
voyez le petit
trait le professeur du jour est Guy le
second capitaine donc le bateau il fait
un petit peu moins de 300 tonnes donc
c'est pas c'est pas une mobylette quoi
il y a de l'inertie il faut
il faut attendre qu' réagisse vous a
j'ai mis 30 secondes pour venir du 250
au
255 donc je revenir donc pour aller vers
250 je
metse aller vers la gauche à
gauche faut pas avoir l' que sur
le regarde aussi
devant
en route au 250 à la barre en route au
250 à la barre en route au
250 souvent on prend un repère terrestre
et par rapport à un ha ban ou n'importe
quoi quelque chose sur le bateau vous
arrivez à voir si vous avez un cap
stable pas
mal
c'est top de voir de voir toutes les les
manœuvres traditionnelles je pense que
je réalisais pas que c'était comme ça en
vraiment c'est c'est quelque chose
d'incroyable on n pas idée de toutes les
les actions qu'il faut faire sur sur ce
voilier je m'attendais pas à ça
[Musique]
vraiment
et pour veiller sur tous ces apprentis
marins il y a le capitaine Tommy
FTI
un bon marin
c'est c'est quelqu'un qui est humble je
pense que la première qualité du marin
c'est l'humilité voilà de de prendre en
compte ce qu'on est en train de leur
apprendre aujourd'hui de prendre en
compte les éléments pour pas aller
contre la mer mais justement avec et ça
c'est voilà c'est vraiment ce qu'il faut
leur apprendre et c'est ce qu'il faut
garder toute sa vie de marin de dire que
c'est c'est la mer qui commande et c'est
pas
[Musique]
nous
la journée se termine dans la rate de
Brest les jeunes marins se préparent à
passer leur première nuit en
[Musique]
mer
au cœur du Pacifique ce matin la pirogue
Faé a mis cap à l'ouest vers les îles
sous le
vent l'équipage est déjà à mchemin de W
sa
[Musique]
destination pour trouver sa route pas de
GPS ni même de
sexant rien à part cette boussole
ancestrale dessinée à même le
pont ça ça s'appelle la campa des
étoiles c'est un compa qui a été créé
par nainoa Thompson le maître navigateur
hawïien inspiré de son maître à lui papa
ma
ma c'est un compa qui
divise le ciel en ce qu'on appelle des
maisons on parle plus en en degré mais
en maison
sachant que chaque maison en fait fait
11,25 de et chaque maison un
an pour n pour le sudest pour NordOuest
et pour le Sud-Ouest une fois qu'on
comprend un peu le système ou
[Musique]
c'est
bien
grâce à cette carte du ciel le soleil et
les étoiles deviennent des repères pour
s'orienter dans l'immensité de
[Musique]
l'océan en plus du compas des étoiles il
faut aussi observer le
[Musique]
vent
et on doit aussi apprendre àruter les
[Musique]
vagues c'est C qu'on veut prendre unet
mais on
prend
voilà
bien unele un peu dominante ici qui nous
pousse comme ça et qui nous qui nous
sort du cap il y a une toute petite HLE
qui nous fait glisser qu'on doit garder
un peu mais entre ces deux il y en a
deux qui se croisent là devant donc
après des fois se perd un peu làdedans
donc pour l'instant
le le Penon il est bien quand
même c'est peut-être le plus difficile à
acquérir mais en fait je pense que c'est
vraiment important parce que le vent il
va souffler dans la même direction
pendant un moment donc on sait que ça va
être
régulier donc c'est c'est quelque chose
de sur lequel on peut compter voà là tu
tu
tu en observant la mer et le ciel il y a
plus de 2000 ans les grands navigateurs
polynésiens ont découvert quasiment
toutes les îles du Pacifique sur leur
petite pirogu à voile ils bravaient
l'océan souvent hostile et naviguai sans
relâche des semaines entières
tous les Polynésiens on est étendu sur
une vaste superficie l'île de P et la
Nouvelle-Zélande et encore on sait nous
queon a été plus loin on est sûr qu'on a
atteint le continent américain et
d'ailleurs on le sait parce que quand on
il y a des tribus indiennes qui ont les
mêmes cultures que nous des mêmes noms
des mêmes pratiques en fait on vivait
sur l'eau aussi et on était uni
justement avec ces îles par l'eau et par
le voyage il y a pas de frontière entre
la terre et la mer donc voilà c'est un
peu c'est notre
humblement c'est notre
[Musique]
pays Tito navigue depuis 10 ans à la
manière de ses ancêtres il fait partie
des quelques rares matres navigateurs au
monde à connaître cette ancienne science
des étoiles des vents et de la mer pas
qu'il faut
ignorer GPS et tout ça non il faut faire
les deux parce que le jour où tu auras
plus rien tu sais tu sais comment il
faut naviguer parce que nos ancêtres
faisaient ça à l'époque c'est not notre
façon de naviguer
c'est tu es plus proche de de la nature
plus à l'écoute que GPS c'est GPS
qui je pense que tous les moyens
technologique à un moment donné ou un
autre peuvent aussi avoir certaines
limites le GPS nous sépare un peu de
toute cette de ce contact avec avec les
éléments puisque on est focalisé sur un
écran tandis que là ben on est
constamment en permanence en
éveil cette expédition de FA faillité
est la première navigation de Moana tu
veux que je reste avec toi tu peux
laisser un petit peu le temps que jeab
mon CAP ouais ok alle allez on lu
monte et là là je suis bien là je suis
stable là ben si moi je lâche
non
tranquille c'est assez physique hein
quand même he enfin en tous les cas pour
moi mais euh bon comp tenu du euh
euh bah la la houle d'une part et puis
du du vent j'ai j'ai j'ai un peu de mal
à stabiliser le
gouvernail pour moi c'est aussi une
découverte de la navigation ancestrale
donc j'apprends et et quand j'ai
quelques repères mais mais je me rends
compte que il y a énormément de choses
avec lesquelles je suis pas encore tout
à fait à l'aise mais mais mais ça va
[Musique]
venir après 20 de voyage la pirogue
arrive sur l'île de
[Musique]
W qu'est-ce que c'est
beau une des îles sous le vent dans
l'archipel de la
Société
l'équipage jette l'encre dans la baie de
Maroué un lagon qui sépare les deux
parties de
l'île ils y resteront quelques heures le
temps de reprendre des
forces j'ai toujours voulu faire partie
de l'aventure jebé
je trouvais ça
incroyable justement que nos ancêtres
ils capter la nature de cette façon je
trouve qu'on a vraiment une belle
[Musique]
culture malgré les apparences pour
l'équipage de
fafé l'initiation est loin d'être
terminée
[Musique]
19h dans la rate de Brest première
soirée sur la belleepoule
pour les jeunes marins ce n'est pas
encore l'heure du
repos
20h minuit
ça Olivier le bosco répartit les équipes
de car les élèves vont se relayer pour
veiller sur le navire avec une
recommandation bien
particulièree bien le plan de couchage
parce que c'est vous qui allez réveiller
vos petits camarades à chaque fois
d'accord donc je veux pas de réveil
c'est clair parce pable qui sonne vous
réveillez tout le bateau d'accord donc
pas de réveil sert à rien si celui qui
si on vous réveille pas on vous réveille
pas d'accord mon avisoublira pas ok ça
marche c'est bon pour vous j'ffich en
passerelle si vous avez un doute vous
hésitez pas voir
ok la première équipe prend son
carart les autres élèves profitent enfin
d'un moment de détente après une journée
éprouvante
il y a toujours quelque chose à faire
c'est que toutes les 10 15 minutes il
faut retendre l'idriss changer les
voiles de côté c'est parce qu'on navigue
avec le vent donc tout est différent en
fait comparé aux autres bateaux ça
développe notre notre sens marin en fait
voà c'est ça nous apprend un peu les
rudiments de la Marine et c'est un petit
peu la base en fait c'est un petit peu
le ciment quoi du marin on ne pique pas
une salade une vie qui est dure qui est
pas forcément facile mais qui qui vaut
la peine d'être vécu
[Musique]
he ce soir Eva et Louis sont
privilégiés ils sont invité à passer un
moment avec le
capitaine vousz pas vu le carécommande
encore non voilà VO B alors le bilan de
cette première journée première
après-midi super on a bien vu que tout
seul on peut rien faire sur ce bateau
hein donc il faut forcément travailler
travailler en équipe travailler ensemble
et ça c'est
ouais ça c'est important enfin en fait
c'est c'est vraiment ça que qu'on qu'on
ve vous apprendre c'est voilà travailler
ensemble pour bah pour tout quoi aprs
donc là bah je suis je suis pour 2 ans
il y a 18 ans le capitaine était lui
aussi un jeune élève de l'École de
mestrance j'ai l'impression de m'être
engagé le mois dernier quoi depuis que
j'étais tout petit j'ai toujours voulu
faire quand je voyais des bateaux
manœuvrés je me disais c'est ça que je
vais faire je veux manœuvrer un bateau
je vais être en passerelle en timonnerie
et puis c'est l'aspect navigateur je me
voyais pas faire autre chose que ça dans
ma
vie il est déjà
23h la Belle Poule est au mouillage pour
la nuit voilà 3h que le premier binôme
veille à la sécurité du navire il
surveille les autres bateaux qui
croisent à
proximité comp par la journée où il y a
tout l'équipage qui est à bord ça bouge
dans tous les sens ouais non on est
tranquille la nuit ouais on est
tranquille on se retrouve un
peu tranquille au calme et puis on a
commencé le à 20h et on finit à minuit
donc bientôt rel va pas
tarderon commence un pe à fatiguer Surts
la
journée la journée qu'on vient de passer
du
coup AR va relever une dernière fois les
données sur la
boussole
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Pauline elle est en charge de réveiller
la prochaine
[Musique]
équipe une tâche qui s'avère
délicate
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour l'équipage de
fafité il est l'heure de remettre cap
sur
papette
[Musique]
avant de partir il change la Baume pour
installer des voiles modernes à la place
des
traditionnel ok tu mér enlever les nœud
ça fait un autre exerc
c'est ça peut
être plus efficace
ok ça attention monter c'est
comme
pour le retour vers Tahiti la mer
s'annonce
calme la nouvelle voilure offre une
meilleure prise au
vent alors le menu ce soir en fait c'est
une petite soupe on va dire à la
chinoise mais fa les
îles parce qu'on fait un petit mélange
de tout onend un peu les produits de
après on rajoute des trucs chinois
dedans et tout ça nous fait la soupe
pour la soirée spécial
fafé voilà on jeter ça et ça sera
[Musique]
bien
tu
[Musique]
tema
tem
protein
[Musique]
l'équipage s'apprête à vivre une
expérience
[Musique]
unique la Pirog va suivre comme
autrefois le chemin des
étoiles on a vu le soleil tomber on a
pris un repère par rapport à l'espace
qui a entre la pointe de l'île et nous
et on va garder ce repère tant que on
voit pas les étoiles puisqu'il fait
encore un peu trop trop jour tout est un
repère tout ce qu'on peut prendre on
peut utiliser comme repère on l'utilise
même des fois ça peut être des oiseaux
qui rentrent à terre et on prend la
direction qui prend parce qu'on sait que
voilà c'est une terre on utilise tout
tout ce qu'il y
[Musique]
a là
c'estcile à côé je c'estis quoi ça pour
trouver son cap il faut donc apprendre à
lire le ciel voilà la carte elle te
permet
de des étoiles que tu reconnais pas
forcément dans le taureau dans le taau
voilà et après je vois un petit groupe
là donc je regarde je
continue
[Musique]
voilà
titoi est le maître des étoiles
àordé
pleintoil pour prière
fois
par pas l'habitude quand regarde le ciel
tes
étoiles pas faire la différence
entre par exemp là en ce moment
il c'est bon est notre cap et après tout
de suite qu tu vois que c'est le cap
maintenant tu prends des des repères on
dit ça des repères des étoiles qui sont
devant qui vont te permettre de garder
ton
cap les étoiles son les meilleurs amis
il nous parle tous les soirs mais c'est
c'est à nous de
de écouter parce on a tellement habité
de regarder en bas pas regarder dans le
ciel nos cêtres trouver tous les îles ça
veut dire c'est
[Musique]
fiable 6h du matin le soleil se lève à
peine sur la rate de
[Musique]
Brest après une courte nuit les élèves
sont à nouveau à pied
[Musique]
d'œuvre c'est la dernière journée de
formation sur la
belleepoule au programme ce matin
une leçon sur le
vent un apprentissage essentiel pour
tout marin qui se
respecte est-ce que vous avez déjà
entendu le terme lou
voyer lou voyer par exemple on va dire
le vent vient comme ça vient de face si
je suis
ici que je dois aller là je vous ai dit
face au V ça marche pas donc on va faire
on va tirer des bords ti des bords 45°g
donc ça c'est sur les bateaux les plus
modernes ici on remonte pas au vent à
45°g mais en gros on va louvoyer donc
c'està-dire on va tirer des bords pour
remonter vers le vent d'accord travers
au vent c'est quand on reçoit le vent
90° par rapport à nous ensuite on passe
au larg grand larg donc larg c'est en
gros quand on l' sur l'arrière un petit
peu ici à bord on fait jamais de vente
arrière c'est pour des problèmes de
grément que quand on est vente arrière
la grand voile à l'arrière la grand
voile la plus grande là elle peut passer
d'un bord ou de l'autre sans qu'on la
contrôle vous avez déjà entendu faites
attention à la tête sur les voiliers à
la Baume tout ça bah nous ici la Baume
fait 800 kg donc si elle part c'est un
coup à casser tout le matériel
d'accord à l'avant du voilier Olivier le
bosco prépare romain à effectuer un
exercice
périlleux sont làut auras deux sécurités
toujours tu auras ton AAP ici le chariot
là qui va te suivre et làhaut tu auras
une
longe je monter en en haut du premier m
pour voir la vue la belle
vue romain se hise au sommet du M de
mizè le m avant de la goélette à plus de
20 m de
haut
[Musique]
cette ascension est l'occasion de
découvrir le rôle d'un autre membre
d'équipage plus méconnu mais tout aussi
essentiel sur un voilier le
[Musique]
gabier donc nous les gabiers les GAB
nous sommes les membres d'équipage qui
s'occupont des des voilesen haut donc on
en a deux principalement la voile d'été
qui se trouve entre les deux m et la
voile de flèche qui se trouve qui
surpombe la grand
voile on peut monter tous les jours voir
plusieurs fois par jour parfois c'est
c'est pas évident les conditions météo
font que ça ça devient un peu un peu un
peu difficile mais comme disait mon
ancien Bosc gabier est censé amener sa
voile part tout temps et tout
àure c'est c'est très impressionnant on
a une très belle vue de là-haut malgré
qu'il y a un petit
un petit
vertige toujours une petite appréhension
de la haute mais sinon c'est très
reposant
apaisant une très belle vue c'est
[Musique]
magnifique la navigation touche à sa fin
la belle pou a mis cap vers le
[Musique]
port les jeunes élèves affalent les
voiles de la goélette c'est leur
dernière manœuvre à
bord
allezour allezou allez
le moment que j'ai préféré pendant ces
jours c'est les différentes manœuvres
qu'on a pu faire avec les voiles changer
de voile parce qu'on changer de
direction en façon du vent c'est c'est
vraiment très intéressant mais aussi
très
[Musique]
physique j'étais vraiment très
impressionné parce qu'il faut vraiment
une très grande force et beaucoup de
cohésion entre entre l'équipage parce
que nos mouvements ils doivent être
coordonné et rythmé surtout c'est c'est
vachement
dynamique j'ai vraiment envie d'être
embarqué voir le lever de soleil tous
les jours d'être d'être en mer vraiment
c'est c'est un environnement qui me
plaît et c'est une vie qui me plaît t
donc ici c'est
naviguer avec des des connaisseurs de de
la voile notamment de la Belle Poule ça
a été très intéressant et très formateur
surtout très formateur j'espérais faire
de de jours de périple
assez assez inoubliable et là ou le sont
inoubliable c'est vraiment ce que je
[Musique]
voulais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en Polynésie c'est la fin du voyage pour
l'équipage de la pyogue
fafité dans 2 he les marins seront de
retour à
papette c'est très simple la vie sur
l'eau et du coup on se dépollue beaucoup
l'esprit on a beaucoup moins de stress
et parce qu'on avec sans instruments on
se rend compte que c'est encore autre
chose c'est un autre niveau parce que on
on est tellement impréigné des éléments
on les observe tellement qu'il a qu'il y
a comme un peu
une quelque chose de magique qui arrive
c'est un petit peu c'est très spirituel
la mère est un grand enseignant la
pyogue aussi ce sont des enseignants
sont des
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maîtres dans l'Atlantique ou le
Pacifique ses marins guident leur bateau
entre hier et
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs en thatien FAF
signifie réconciliation
[Musique]